flying over this scenic terrain in
western Kenya it's hard to miss the
devastation on the ground it was caused
by a huge mud slide after two rivers
past their banks it's been raining
heavily for days in the more mountainous
areas and the impact is felt in this
area the Kenyan counties of ljo marques
and West / courts this is where Chesser
gone Market stood until rocks came
crashing down also destroying homes
shops and restaurants hundreds of people
lined the town market on Saturday
afternoon Stanley curry ran a butcher's
shop and was hoping to sell 24 goats
that day all but four was swept away by
the torrent of mud I want people to
leave this area when the Ramban started
but they would not believe me they do
not think the water would get there now
we have lost many of our loved one as
well as our car - got an data property
this was a thriving trading centre in a
town of about 3,000 people those we
talked to say when they had rumbling up
this continent and so water dashing down
they ran for safety but others were not
so lucky several people have died
dozens are still missing rescue
operations by the government Red Cross
and other agencies are still going on
among the bodies retrieved so far a 14
year old girl the area is difficult to
get to
roads were swept away and bridges down
without heavy equipment to help dig
through the rubble young volunteers use
sticks to look for bodies the volunteers
have also rescued several people
including Evelyn Koo toy then if there's
a khabees onion and the water was so
much I just let it take me I don't know
how long I was in it but it felt like an
hour I thought I would die every time I
found a tree branch to hold on to the
water would take me back under I just
don't know how I survived she's among
thousands who've lost everything
many are sheltering with neighbors who
are on higher ground the same area was
struck by another
it's like killing 60 people last
November the government says the
community needs to move to safer ground
many like Evelyn Tallis they have
nowhere else to go
Catherine SOI al Jazeera Tessa gone
western Kenya